I'm a 17 year old,
I'm a blue belt in Jujitsu,
which I received a few days after my 16th birthday and I have ambitions of
pursuing Jujitsu professionally and competing to the highest level possible.
Of course,
this requires discipline and commitment.
So during the school term,
I trained you to two Monday through Saturday and I weight train on Friday and
Sunday.
And when I have time off school,
I trained you two to three times a day.
However,
due to my commitment to this and my refusal to prioritize the other things over
this,
I feel I'm missing out on the social opportunities of this part of my life.
I Miss Parties and social events in order to stranger Jujitsu and weight train
because I know that I should have the discipline to do so,
however I feel lonely and isolated because of it.
Is this just weakness or should I make the occasional exception for a social
event?
Once again,
love the work you do,
you and echo do.
It's how it's helped me immensely.
Thanks from the UK.
All right.
The UK.
Um,
first of all,
I'd just,
okay.
The hardcore hears that the couple of hardcore answers,
the hardcore nerds number,
what's your schedule like?
Right?
Are you wasting any time?
Have you,
have you maxed them?
Maximize the hours you can get out of a day?
Or are you spending time doing other things that you shouldn't be doing?
That being said,
it sounds like you're getting after it pretty hard,
which means you're probably pretty efficient.
And if you're,
if you're
not wasting a bunch of time and you're not doing a bunch of things that are non
productive and you're feeling lonely and isolated,
then guess what?
You're going too far.
You don't,
you should not be feeling lonely and isolated.
That's not good.
You need to relax.
Especially because if you're training that much,
you're likely overtraining.
So broadly speaking,
now,
broadly speaking,
training should be enjoyable.
Okay?
This doesn't mean that you're gonna love it every day.
And I talk about that all the time.
It doesn't mean every day you wake up and you're all,
you know,
smile from one ear to the other year cause you're so happy you got to go do you
know,
squats and dead lifts like no,
that doesn't happen.
But broadly the way it makes you feel,
the way Jujitsu makes you feel should make it,
are there times when you go on the you to Matt and you get spanked and you get
ground out and you get tapped out and you feel like junk.
Yes,
that going to happen.
But again,
broadly,
how does you do to make you feel?
It makes you feel good.
You should enjoy it to some extent,
right?
And you should not be getting burnt out.
And I think that's the most important thing is that you shouldn't be getting
burnt out on Jujitsu,
on working out.
And,
and this is,
this is important,
especially for your 17 years old.
There is more to life than Jujitsu and physical fitness,
right?
There's more to,
there's more to,
there's more to doing well in life than just Jujitsu and physical fitness.
So a couple things.
If you can't,
you can't like communicate with people effectively.
That's a real problem in any environment,
right?
And if you're isolating yourself from other people and you're not,
you're not learning how to interact with other human beings in a social
environment,
that's not good.
And it's not only,
it's not only that,
it's,
it's just not good for you because yes,
you as a person,
you need to be well rounded.
You need to be,
yes,
you need to be strong,
you need to be capable from a fighting perspective,
but you all still need to be smart.
You need to be articulate,
you need to be quick.
Witted
and those things are mandatory skills in life.
I mean,
if you're a black belt in Jujitsu and you're a white belt and communicating with
other human beings,
that's not going to be a good situation for you.
And the other thing is,
the better you are,
the more well rounded you are in all these other aspects of life of those things
will actually make you better at Jujitsu.
Cause you'll be able to read people,
you'll be able to deal with confrontation.
You'll be able to understand other people's motivations and all those things
come from interacting with other human beings.
So I get it.
I get the massive commitment and that is what it takes.
Like if you want to compete at the highest level,
I'm telling you,
yes,
you have to live,
breathe and eat Jujitsu.
You have to live,
breathe and eat conditioning.
And that being said,
if that's all you live,
breathe and eat,
that's going to make you less apt to be a champion.
Then if you make yourself a little bit more well rounded in some of these other
aspects.
So dude,
keep training hard.
17 year old blue belt from UK.
Keep training hard,
go out occasionally hang out with some people.
Yeah,
have a good time.
And that by no means means get hammered every time you do it at all.
Not at all.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That social aspect,
man,
that's like this.
It seems like a lot of times,
especially when you're training,
are you doing something that's kind of directly or can be viewed as like
directly opposite of a social thing?
Because you know,
when you think socially you're thing call,
you guys are just slacking,
you know,
going to the Bar,
cruising at the beach,
whatever.
Well,
while we're over here training kind of thing.
Right.
Just like,
just like people say,
Oh,
you're sleeping on the couch,
you know,
what are you lazy sleeping on the couch with.
I Dunno.
Maybe they need rest,
you know,
or make there's,
there's,
there is use in sleep.
Seems like that was a,
that was a little,
maybe kind of a glimpse into the Echo Charles world right there.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
Nonetheless,
you sleep on the couch,
maybe I need rest.
Maybe I'm recovering from the workout.
I'm saying,
I'm saying there's two parts of it,
you know,
that there's that.
And so in
people give it a bad rap,
I think.
Especially like you,
you know how like,
you know,
you hear these,
motivational gurus grind all sleep when I'm dead,
you know,
that kind of thing.
Right?
Yeah.
So I,
you said it,
not me,
but hey,
all right.
So,
and I'm not saying that,
you know,
that's dumb or nothing like that.
I'm saying,
I'm saying that it produces a certain message that can be interpreted in a way
that might not be the most beneficial.
Well,
I'm sure I think this,
this,
I'm glad that he asked this question because he's taken the attitude of like,
okay,
I'm going to sleep when I'm dead and I'm going to,
I'm going to hang out with other human beings after I'm a world champion.
Right?
And again,
do you need to be possessed to be world champion?
Yes,
you do.
But all I'm saying is part of the things that will make you be a better well
rounded person,
the more well rounded you are,
the better you're going to perform.
You know,
you're going to learn how to deal with anxiety.
You're going to learn how to deal with people.
You're gonna learn how to look at someone else's situated,
look in their eyes and be like,
okay,
this guy's stressed out,
or this guy's panicking,
or this guy,
you know,
you learn those things from interacting with other people.
That's going to make you a better competitor.
You're going to learn more about yourself.
Yeah,
and you're going to be,
if you,
if you relax now,
what you don't want to do is go so far in the other direction where you,
where you show up to a competition,
you don't feel like you've prepared as much as you could,
but that,
what does that,
do you go too far in the other direction now you overtrained yeah,
so you've got to find a little bit of,
but sounds like you're a little bit off balanced,
especially cause you're feeling like the words that kind of keyed me off the
most in this was what was it?
Lonely and isolated.
That's what kind of key,
if you said everything else here and then you were like,
um,
am I over training?
I would have said,
Nah man,
you're getting after it.
Good job.
But then when you say,
look,
I feel lonely and isolated.
You don't want to feel lonely and isolated.
Like,
and that's another thing when I trained Jujitsu,
that's kind of where I hang out.
Like I don't interact with people normally it's a social thing.
We might not even talk.
We might not even say one word other than do you want a roll?
And then we train.
That's sort of my social activity of,
of hanging around with other people and I don't feel I leave the gym and I feel
like I hung out with a lot of people.
I didn't say anything to him.
But if you feel lonely and isolated,
that's not good.
That's getting to you.
That means your mind is starting to be worn down from this.
Don't let it get worn out.
It's going to refuel you to go out.
It's gonna Watch this,
watch this.
If you're feeling lonely and isolated,
your workout that day is like a nine.
If you feel like like,
Hey,
I'm having a good life.
I'm,
I'm filled with energy.
I like hanging out.
I just,
you know,
had a good time with this girl last night and now I'm going to train.
It's like,
oh,
okay,
guess what?
That out to 9.7 you get a better training cause you had a good time.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
I don't like to,
I don't like the fact that he says he's lonely and isolated desk,
not good.
And of,
again,
this is just a dichotomy because then you'll get someone that says,
okay,
well Jocko would go out and you don't have party,
you know,
party party with the ladies and then the whole Mexico.
Yeah.
It'll help my workout.
And then,
well,
you know,
maybe if I only work out three times a week and I spend most of my time
partying,
I'll be just,
I'll get workouts level 11.
No you won't.
So yeah,
man,
make some exceptions to your discipline and go enjoy the company of some other
people.
Grow a little bit as a person.
Become a better human,
compete better,
train harder.
That's it.
I agree,
man.
This is a concept that I think is,
if you can kind of incorporate or understand this concept in,
you know,
when you're working hard at something.
So when I was young,
when I first started lifting weights,
first started,
I don't know,
15 or however old.
Um,
so you know,
you know how when you lift weights and you get that little pump right to me,
to me,
I thought that that's literally my muscles growing.
You know,
like I didn't know how it all worked.
I was like,
Dang,
my mom said I can see the growth already.
So all they gotta do is lift every single day and watch out quick.
You know,
cause most people they won't work as hard as me cause I'll just,
cause I liked doing it.
I like the pump,
whatever.
Um,
so I would do,
we remember the guy,
my friend I mentioned Eric Masters pilot in the air force.
Yes.
So he,
he had the one,
he always said the soda above the microwave there.
Anyway,
so I lived with him,
Him and his dad would invite me and my brother over,
we'll,
we'll live with and he started off with bench and you know,
this stuff.
So w we go lift and I'm like,
Dang,
I feel a pump.
So now when I,
when we trend kind of went into,
I want to say like forest city football,
I don't know.
Anyway,
we were,
we started lifting in the weight room at the high school,
so I would do the same thing every single day,
every single day,
every single day.
And my friend was like,
this other guy I know.
He goes,
hey you are you benching every single day?
And I was like,
yeah.
And he was like,
Bro,
your muscles aren't going to grow.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
Of course they do.
They grow every single day.
Like I feel it even he's like,
Bro,
you don't know how it works.
He's like,
you don't,
when you lift they don't grow.
They actually get torn and they get like almost like a little micro injury that
that's how it works.
And then when you rest and when you sleep and when you eat and they grow and I
was like,
and he did,
it still didn't make sense.
So I was like,
okay,
I guess,
you know,
he's like,
you ever heard,
you know when the soreness,
you know when you get the soreness or whatever.
I was like,
yeah.
He was like,
that's like it,
like hurt,
like kind of injured or whatever,
and then it has to heal up and when it heals up,
it heals up bigger.
And I'm like,
okay.
It's like,
so you can't bend every day.
Otherwise it'll just like,
it'll just won't grow it always be damaged.
I was like,
oh,
makes sense.
So that rest in between workouts,
it's kind of important given my goal Grosso muscles,
and you'll see what I'm saying,
where this kind of thing,
where it's like all go,
all go,
no arrest.
Right?
You need that rest to grow literally.
And that goes for anything.
Truth.